[Musik]
wenn ich einen film zum thema angst
realisieren heißt das auch sich den
eigenen ängsten zu stellen
wer wird es schnell zu eng so laut zu
viel
im gedränge fühle ich mich unwohl möchte
weg aber ich habe keine panik attacken
wie viele menschen die unter angst
störung einer psychischen erkrankung
leiden oft ohne erkennbaren auslöser
werden sie von ängsten befallen
sie erleben diese als einen sog aus dem
sie kaum mehr herauskommen
das ist jetzt in betrieb
sie zogen einen ausstieg sich mit der
langstrecke wahnsinn gefehlt meter und
verdrängt haben
die will die bilder anschaue nicht eine
situation stellen und mit damals oft zum
verfahren vi nachsteht werden darüber
nicht
jedes mal richtig richtig super dass ich
hatte ein bisschen hoch strukturen auf
einer hyperventilieren
was ist passiert und das ist dann zu tun
und mit ihr machen helfen
ich bin nur der untergrund ist gerade
die band möglichkeit jederzeit liegen
sogar noch irgendwie bis oft später
treten ich hatte geschrieben die lage
jetzt da nach der bis zur nächsten
station
und wir haben ich bin total auf dem taxi
und notenbank sind und wann immer sie
kommen so beraten und dann ist der
mieter tragen musste minimieren die zu
geschichte das hat sich wirklich hart
über die letzten 25 jahre alt und das
wird jetzt so easy
ziemlich easy haben das ist für die
tiere
das kommt später flexibel ist aber
gerade dann zu tier wurde anna sophie im
90 grad winkel walken und wandern durch
die ankommt also es gibt ein relevantes
brennelement wo du nicht einfach
beliebig beliebig und flexibel schweizer
marcel meier ist ein erfolgreicher
projektleiter und verkäufer in der möbel
und einrichtung special als ich ihn
kennenlernte wäre ich nie auf die idee
gekommen dass er schon jahrzehntelang
unter einer angststörung leidet seit
seiner jugend doch seine krankheit wurde
lange nicht richtig erkannt und
behandelt
marcel meier hat es irgendwie
durchgestanden
ich habe mir die bildet das die störung
eines minensuchen stand entstanden ist
die job com sowie schon erhalten und der
soziale kontext war in unternehmen also
i got und die politik des damaligen
rezept ganz typisch sie ihn besser
bewerkstelligen vergangen verdrängen das
ist natürlich eine besser gemacht hat
ich weiß gar nicht was du da gestanden
und wahrscheinlich ganz auf die mittel
vertraut das tue ich kann eigentlich
immer gewusst dass irgendwann zone
bekommt und hat offensichtlich kraft und
energie kann abschluss auf dass sie das
irgendwie hier im norden wie sagt
bestanden
die für jeden anderen menschen auch
gehirn ängste zu meinem leben als
filmemacher
je älter ich werde desto ängstlicher
werde ich
eine allgemeine ängstlichkeit die sich
nur manchmal konkret festmachen lässt
früher konnte ich problemlos in der
ganzen welt herumreisen heute fällt mir
ein größerer ortswechsel schweren
sobald ich meinen alltagstrott aufgeben
muss werde ich unsicher
coly grossenbacher führt seit acht
jahren mit ihrem mann kocht ein
restaurant auf einem großen sportplatz
vor 17 jahren erlebt sie ihre erste
panikattacke bei ausbruch ihr angst
krise betrieben sie noch das schöne
quartier restaurant blume eine
aufreibende arbeit deshalb gaben sie
später die blume auf
bereichen
im jahr 2000 im november und zwar nicht
mit mini yours frauen dazu motiviert
auch ovi store buben und die nachricht
hat mich dann am morgen um darüber mit
zurück ins hotel wo sie in der richtigen
box von natur und ich hatte eine
überstürzte heirat mit
die finma betreffe und hat das zum glück
überlebt aber für mich ist dieser traum
maxim auch er fröhlich durch ihre
panikattacken angefangen
ich habe das gar nicht so einfach ist
körperlich und angst als ich dann im
restaurant zusammenbricht vor ort sein
und sterben
und schlimmsten ob sie das gefühl das
ist für mich das alles völlig und
grundgedanke dass mir so etwas passieren
ich bin ich in beiden dabei helfen boote
ich bin bodenständig wachsen kann und wo
psychische probleme können die menschen
belächelt will kommt es momentan in die
betriebe und dann hat es mir möglich
aber reicht wenn ich mir vorgestellt
hab' mir chronik was passiert ist kann
ich mir aufgeschrieben betrug 78 kam
impuls klasse normalwert dass auch die
höhe betrachtet betrug real 103 77 und
der mini symptom monika herz rose als
stachel links atemnot und schwindel und
das komische kribbeln in den fingern als
arbeitswille den finger und das einst
geschrieben und an den blöcken
arbeitsbereit und hat ein grünes licht
dann merken sie was das klacken ist dass
ich jetzt gestorben bin
und dann baut doch später als sehr
schmal untertags verwünscht am
sonntagmittag werde mit auxerre ist akut
im kochbuch eigentlich fix und alle
durch trimmel und sich nicht übertrieben
viel los sie immerhin trotzte aber nicht
gestresst überhaupt nicht und plötzlich
ist das wieder losgegangen und direkten
auch immer ganz bleich wurde und wird so
kotick hugos unterseite was ist los mit
dir
es geht wieder los daraus wird dann hat
man immer im herzen einer sitzen und der
serviertochter griff zu drogen elite sie
sind dann relativ schnell taxi und
einzig im kranken wieder das mobile nico
erkrankt und entweder nie gefunden
sie haben mich dann aber nach oben ganz
aktuell wieder ins spital verbracht
derselbe ekg als ohne befund wieder
beruhigungstablette und 31
[Musik]
claudia moser hat zwei kinder
sela und julia seit langem lebt sie ohne
feste beziehung bereits in ihrer jugend
erlebte panikattacken und es entwickelte
sich eine starke angststörung
trotzdem schaffte sie es immer wieder im
pflegerischen bereich arbeit zu finden
und die kleine familie alleine
durchzubringen
seit einem jahr nun bezieht sie nach
langen abklärungen eine volle invalid
gewählte am ersten drehtag sagte claudia
moser mir dass sie in der letzten woche
seit langem wieder eine akute
angststörung durchlebt hatte der
versorger das ist schlimm
[Musik]
die beruhigende gang in eine therapeutin
täglich die ware zu mir hey unser
schlimmer war und sie ihre koffer und
ich sage und eine gute freundin von mir
selber jahrzehnte lang papier nach
kupfer
die grenze des wortes ihrer laufen naja
eine spätromantische weniger auto fahren
wie es mir geht und das rad ist eine
heiße spur ist oder als wäre der straße
habe ich diese grenze kommen hier vater
und die salzach locker und jetzt wird
wieder laufen würde ich eben schlimm wie
in offenburg mit reporter besorgen
schlimmster vorstellen was es genau wie
ich sage es ist genau hier grenzen in
deutschland einzigartig
[Musik]
dessen licht fahren ist für marcel meier
beinahe unmöglich nicht weil er an
höhenangst leidet sondern weil er keine
fluchtmöglichkeit hat
ich meide solche fahrten auch über
schwindelerregende ab könnte objektiv
betrachtet ist der sessellift eines der
sichersten transportmittel
doch das nützt nichts wenn große ex im
spiel sind
andererseits sind ängste
überlebensnotwendig und schützen uns
deshalb lernen wir schon als kind
gefahren richtig einzuschätzen und
ängste zu überwinden
[Musik]
diese schlagen immer kam bestimmt
schafft sie dann kannst du im raum
schaffen und somit eher körperliche
niveau sie abfangen
es kühlt es dann auf dem stuhl kann
direkt ganz abgeschafft was man soll auf
ich bin schon richtig und schob sie also
hyperventilieren gefühle der brust und
dann gibt es andere nicht aus dann mit
dem auto noch knapp knapp geschafft
[Musik]
das ist nicht gang bedeutet ohne kommen
und haben ein bisschen gebraucht bis es
auch diejenige masse wie darüber nach
oben und unter schock der sitzung nehmen
oder pizzerien im norden an die stange
und das ist einigermaßen und will die
panikattacken im kreis stattgefunden hat
jetzt kann ich das nicht gemacht und
dann aber so vermerkte nicht wohl in der
mitte wieder heim sprechen kann
für mich und das war nicht ganz leicht
gemacht ist ein podium geschafft
therapeutisch natürlich haben wir nicht
geschafft und bin immer ist sie ja nicht
die ganze last gelegt weil man so will
das merken darüber reden es ist wichtig
die kräfte die obwohl ich es ist sehr
schwierig ich probiere das jetzt
beschrieben
das war dann so richtig im schuber bis
es geht wieder
es gibt weniger ausgang es nun geschafft
dass gewinne drucke zu stop und ist
zudem das verreisen muss das klingt man
hört und das klingt dann dann
alarmstimmung also der tarif der redet
klingt man damit über das interview
indirekt dann mir gut zureden und
haschisch obama kann so schlimm ist es
kann nicht jedes mal und ich kann
verteilt über die letzten riskiert um
seinen zweiten mannschaft auch gekommen
ist entsetzt laden von müsse jetzt ein
scheiß
[Musik]
flugangst ist ein weit verbreitetes
phänomen ich habe angst vor einem
absturz und beruhige mich in dem ich mir
sage dass flugzeuge zu den sichersten
transportmitteln gehören
[Musik]
flüchten ist eine häufige reaktion bei
angststörungen
für corny grossenbacher ist das schlimme
im flieger das ausgeliefertsein keine
kontrolle zu haben
das wäre anders wenn sie selber die
pilotin wäre dafür machen für das hoch
sie lag mit saloppen oder blumen oben
und ich hätte die kasseler helfen
chancen schenken und verteilen und so
machen wie ich bin die galaxie zum
gehilfen attacke kurz nacht und dann
noch eine schlaufe und den acht minuten
fertig sind noch da habe ich mir keine
besucher zu schaffen dann ist eine opera
kochen und zwei kolleginnen von mir sind
auf dem hof sich gottex wo sie einen
eigenen treffer nach mir gefragt was los
ist und der tasten verzählt
die einzige gute kollegin psychiater und
die andere ab sonntag panikattacke
beiden sofort greifen um ihn vor dem
psychischen und ich sollte unbedingt
und dann ich sehr gut dass das ganzen
haben wirklich kritisch dass das
wirklich gibt dass die symptome
typisch sind wird aus dass ich nicht
allein bin
und vor allem dass man mir helfen und
was ganz wichtig sich am anfang habe ich
zu meiner tochter jeep zum das gucken
abklären
das heißt ich bin im neuenburg sieger
blut musste sie sachen untersuchen
wollten sie und da bin ich meine
herzspezialisten sitzungen notarzt rasch
alle machen und das ist sehr wichtig für
mich anfangs körperlicher definitiv
ausschließen dass es ernsthaft ist und
dass am tag wie sicherheit und natürlich
gesprächstherapie ich bin sehr strömen
die woche in psychiatrie wieso führer
stunde zählt zu den größten gefahren ist
wirklich - halten
was dies für möglichkeit zum entspannen
und wenn ich mich als verrückte maniche
der apa keine haben zwischen tun das mit
einem festessen auf nimmt dass ich mich
so an
im brustkorb oder im oberkörper und vor
allem das kasimir lösen dass ich noch
mal wieder vielleicht rufen und das habe
ich dann eher weniger angst
[Musik]
ich gehe nie an große fest anlässe
einem gedränge weil ich aus im kino
sieht sich am rand
[Musik]
mittendrin kann ich es aushalten doch
ich vermeide es wenn möglich
[Musik]
claudia moser hingegen geht nie ins kino
auch nicht an andere öffentliche
veranstaltungen
ja
wie sicher fühlen zufluchtsort und
renten in herforder die soziale kontakte
außerdem muss die heimat wenn es eine
möglichkeit gibt claudia moser muss mit
dem auto möglichst nahe heran fahren
können
so kann sie in kleinen leben die er
vertraut sind einkaufen
der parkplatz muss unmittelbar vor dem
geschäft liegen
die pläne noch die strecken wieder
aufgenommen der großvater demnach großen
paket an
sie schütze titel hatte sie hoffe dass
die frau ihr anteil welcher das sein mag
es ja und zwar stets dass die ganze
spruch der ganze druck weg ist muss wenn
gelächter die ganze belastung und
fordern okoro absteigen ist nämlich
gegen verziehen
finanzielle probleme bezirk ja dass das
bugfixing gebietsleiter mit dem wetter
größere programm ihnen besser jobs hatte
keinem etwas bleibt bin ich mit meinen 1
stunde vor dem essen nach rang sechs
mitarbeiter damit nur krieg
ich besuche mit marcel meier das
sanatorium kirchberg eine psychiatrische
klinik
dort wurde er vor zehn jahren mit einer
akuten angststörung sechs monate lang
stationär behandelt 20 jahre nach seiner
ersten panikattacke bekam er hier
endlich eine klare diagnose einen namen
für seine krankheit und ein für
angstpatienten bewährtes therapieangebot
arbeitsplatzsituation kosovo sehr
schwierig und später ein quasi auf
knopfdruck christin missbrauchs muss in
kriminelle und und bin schlafen morgens
gepackt und bis zum rathaus gerufen und
benehme zurückkommen dann habe ich mich
entschlossen nichts gerechtfertigt
ich kann sehr gute erinnerungen verbinde
sie eine mit ich bin das nicht per se
mit lag damals ist man den großen schlag
gegangen sondern es ist sehr stark sie
eigentlich abschotten start wieder in
selbstbestimmter das steuerrad wie
drüben hand vor den acht jahre lang oder
jahrzehnte lang fest
der oberarzt damals geschrieben und
geschrieben
ganz am schluss werden minute xhaka und
übrigens hektar ab und an in katar der
katastrophe verschwiegen und derzeitigen
kern stand so close aber fünf minuten
hintergangen wichtigste zum schluss
freut über sein so und so so haben es
therapieren
die und die möglichkeit ist da schon
richtig sie arbeitet kreaturen ist
in der klinik musste marcel meier sich
zuerst einem harten entzug von einem
süchtig machenden beruhigungsmittel
unterziehen
dieser dauerte einige wochen erst
nachher konnte man mit der exposition
therapie beginnen und der begleitung
einer fachperson der psychologin karin
hammer fällt konfrontierte sich marcel
meier mit situationen die bei ihm ängste
auslösen beispielsweise musste er einen
weg unter freiem himmel zurücklegen
mit der zeit lernte er so sich seinen
ängsten zu stellen und diese
schrittweise abzubauen
doch weil ich mich erinnere dass das
plateau haben das haben wir besprochen
dass ich probiere grund funktioniere ja
nicht verdrängen
lose angst 1 bis 10 haben überhaupt und
wenn ja wie häufig sie wird wird 2010
ich dann nicht exponiert und larven
stieg sie wie fühle ich mich als ob
ribery die konkrete auseinandersetzung
gehört haben muss jetzt besonders danken
dass ich das überhaupt überstehen
das ist natürlich nicht sondern eher im
gegenteil das wenn sie merken dass sie
abdriften gedanklich dass sie wirklich
versuchen wieder zu angst zurückzukehren
wie sie anders als damals ja das ist
zwischen grundwort zone also forscht
komfortzone die die situation ob es das
dauern frau die eigentlich in zug
gestiegen also natürlich ist es im
inneren erinnerung aber ich sehe wie
sehr weit weg
er hat jetzt super abgas problems sie
und kann ich natürlich erinnere wie das
tor nachdem eine erste exposition sie am
triebweg sie haben können sie sich dann
noch erinnern was die ängste waren diese
hier mit dem feld verbunden
also natürlich darf vor der angst dass
das dass das altbekannten und tiefer
legen die verlegung das war nicht jetzt
schreibe ich arbeite die stadt muss
haben wir nicht die früchte
also greift 30 hat quasi um eine
weiterfahrt das hat mir extrem mir
gemacht kann mich also nicht mehr geben
allein unterwegs dann wirklich alleine
versuchen panikattacken hier bin und das
ist wahrscheinlich eine andere auslöser
für nachher dass man verbindet mit einer
erstkontakt oder der erste laden ist
eines meiner kamera
für fachleute sind die auslöser von
panikattacken meist erkennbar aber die
tiefer liegenden ursachen dieser
erkrankung liegen nach wie vor im
dunkeln
es gibt auch keine spezifischen
medikamente gegen angststörungen
angstlösende antidepressiva linden zwar
die angst verhindern sie aber nicht und
beruhigungsmittel benzodiazepine lassen
die angst nur kurz verschwinden und
machen abhängig
medikamente können sogar kontraproduktiv
sein
es geht darum dass der betroffene sich
mit seinen ängsten auseinander setzt und
lernt mit ihnen umzugehen
jeffrey sich natürlich auf 71 prozent
des volks sie wie sie hat einfach nur
überwinden und durch ein schwieriges
richter und als 100 liter ist ja klar
ich das nicht könnte den übersichten los
gehts dann umfragen problem ist aber
auch als panikmache für sap ist und man
muss ist die auch zum verständnis von
sieht das ist einfach auch mal gerade
nicht machen
loos bildete doch der wirkliche alter
rollerfahrer wie ich auch nicht was da
für mich ist es einfach schwierig
sitzung
das ganze braucht verstauen
damit richtet sich das verständnis
begriff nicht ich glaube ich aus einem
traum es ist
ich sagte ja gott sei dank sehr guten
dir analytics und eine dunkle hose
[Musik]
dann hat ein modell für mikrofone
sprechen sich zum psychiater und dann
hat er sich fragen stellen und dann die
psychotherapeutin
doch wir machen ich spüre selber was mag
verliehen
wie viel das militär und produktiv sie
eigentlich damit den erst recht unter
druck gesetzt und das ist nicht gut
welche klasse
ruft man sowieso damit konfrontiert wird
aber nicht erwartet
und mit dem hofstaat hat das rund und
auch nicht in der tiefe sinn gemacht
situationen mit ihm nach
das ist
das ist mir wirklich
der immer vermisse das im inneren der
wittorfer wenn man das bild für mich
irgendwie nicht irgendein bürger
gewandete mit rucksäcken der
tagesausflug machen dass man ja auch
immer machen wollte ich das war von mir
ein schmerzhaftes steht schon ganz
wichtig es ist nicht so schlimm
angst ist auf unerträglich und kann
unserem leben hindern
aus angst vor panikattacken entwickeln
viele betroffene vermeidungsstrategien
und nehmen beispielsweise wegen tunnels
große umwege in kauf wenn die
lebensgestaltung durch ängste all zu
stark eingeschränkt wird ist eine
therapie notwendig
[Musik]
ich habe gelernt dass ich dafür meetings
taktik muss man also muss muss aktuell
sondern dass sie etwas probieren mit dem
stelle und dann die situation jetzt
spielen und ich hoffe das problem
[Musik]
außerdem ist
der welt umgeht
und das gut überstanden
durch medikamente
der ganze weg und das war's dann für
mich vielleicht wieder einen gang
runterschalten user so einfach sich
selber hand wieder und nicht einfach mit
dem home staging ihnen blieben und sich
verrückt machen
der ev zug stoch und definieren ja schon
ein student das ist bricht er ab jetzt
hoffnungslos aber die sagt wir haben
[Musik]
sie konzentrieren und damit auf eine
seilbahn claudia und dann spazieren
das sollte haben zusammen das irgendwie
geht
das kann man aber den kontakt zu den
herstellern gut
auch wenn ich mich beim wunsch ertappe
erste klasse zu fahren
einkaufszentren grundsätzlich meiden und
türme und gipfel lieber gar nicht
besteigen leide ich nicht an
überbordenden angstzuständen trotzdem
merke ich wie die grenzen fließend sind
die frage wo die krankheit beginnt ist
auch für fachleute nicht einfach zu
beantworten und die betroffenen müssen
sie sich selber stellen
20 auch bilder im sanatorium sieht ralf
berghaus jahr binden frank leppek sie
und hat ein tiefer sondern auch das
weitere programm könner machen
wahrscheinlich mit dem dürftigen sowie
stifte coni ohne leistungsdruck und hat
die quartiere motor wieder können
der urvater und hat ein
abschlussgespräch karben iv beraten und
dann gefunden ich schaffe das nicht
zurück und haben wir 50 prozent
antworten und ich bin ein ziemlich
verrücktes grund überhaupt in frage und
zwar 100 prozent an die erste panne
gestartet und habe mich dann für
minütigen anders vorgestellt
dann ist nur schwierig sich oder nur
schlecht hören nämlich 737 und bietet
eine sehr oft sie kann ich sehr gut
erinnere das gespräch mit dem damaligen
extrem viel verständnis gehabt und kunde
hat mich interessiert nicht was vor
aktiv sondern ich werde jetzt wir sind
es ja nur zukunft und die chance verkehr
und bin jetzt seit sieben jahren gegen
arbeitgeber
das hilft sehr dass ich nicht vom
arbeitgeber quasi drucken und die wissen
wollen was mit mir los ist
das erfolgreich und sie setzt auf mich
und sie hätte mir ist und das gemüse
natürlich
[Musik]
was sie aber nie loswerden und das ist
auch so ist das hier angst klaas in
ständiger begleiter ist und und und ich
haben und das ist damals ziel der
therapie von der letzten jahre dass es
darum geht dass sich ein adäquater
umgang damit finden also das ist quasi
wie annehmen es ist zwar kein freund die
angst und und und dann geht's halt
besser die zeit und es geht weniger um
titel und meine ich sage dass ich das
quasi über wunder haben dann heißt das
nicht dass ich nebenher panikattacke
haben
und wo immer nur entweder wir dran zu
zweifler hat ein ganzes oft wie und wo
normale menschen es gab nur rund 250
rahmen in kanada und alltag bewältigen
na super eine pause brauche wie viel
davon trinken am besten
das fängt die stimmung noch heute
überhaupt nicht verstehen
und dann wieder mal so ein anflug von
panik attacke um das heißt über stufe
mit ruhig durchaus wieder weg das sind
pro sekunde so dass dann nur dass dann
wieder rund und wider willen ist für
mich so ja schon alte bekannte zu mir
ich kann gut damit
und das belastet mich nehmen
[Musik]